the ingredients for a great recipe are
something that is accessible I would say
it's important that people can get
whatever ingredients are calling for
ultra seasonal is another thing that's
very important I think for a great
recipe that makes sense for you're not
going to use kind of Fuji apples from
New Zealand because you know that
they've come thousands of thousands of
miles and they may not be that fresh
you're going to use something that's
much more indigenous to right where you
live and then something a recipe that
has been clearly written because I have
worked with a lot of chefs in the past
and chef recipes are particularly hard
they're written in these kind of wild
ways that presume a ton of knowledge and
usually aren't make great quantities or
food so chef recipes are always the most
difficult with us for us to work with